every day the water shrinks back a
little bit more
burrito reservoir on the edge of
dartmoor is less than half full
locals can see the level dropping
and it's a worry for the likes of krish
kumar who's been visiting for more than
30 years
never seen it not not at this this level
this low level no
it has been
it's usually quite high up it's scary
it really is scary because it's going to
affect a lot of people with the water
supply
it's a concern obviously um
you know obviously
the way the climate seems to be going
it's only going to get worse and as i've
just said then plymouth's a growing city
they're constantly building houses
in 1893 work started on excavating for
the foundations the rock had to be cut
entirely by hand the reservoir was built
more than 120 years ago to supply the
growing city of plymouth and nearby
villages
it's as vital now as it was then
even at this time of year the level of
this reservoir should be higher it's
down nearly 60 percent on its capacity
and this dry land is a really stark
image for the surrounding communities
that rely
on this water
a mile away at mivie village hall every
drop counts it's the annual flower show
but there's a drought and that means
fewer entries
it has made life difficult things have
either gone over and some of the flowers
i was out in the garden yesterday and
looking at them and they've just
gone over the reservoir is the lowest
i've seen it since i've lived here and
that's 28 years
and
things are getting desperate
across the green locals seek shelter
from the sun at the royal oak
using the washing up water to water the
garden instead of
fresh water well a couple months ago
went on to water meter
and that's made me even more conscious
of the water that we use i think people
you know have got to realize we're going
to be in this situation for years to
come
you're not worried
yeah yeah you know climate change
it's frightening
while there's no drought on beer it's
water and the lack of it that's hitting
this small corner of dartmoor like it is
across much of the country
and white is sky news at burrito
reservoir in devon